Trascrizione: Eleonora Fantinel
Revisore: Giorgia Borsellino
Benvenuti
al Museo Nazionale della Scienza e della
Tecnologia “Leonardo da Vinci” di Milano.
Da qui parte il mio viaggio
con questo speech dal titolo
“Guida Galattica
per giovani disorientati
in era post-lockdown”.
È un titolo volutamente leggero
proprio perché usciamo da un periodo,
quello della pandemia e
dell’emergenza sanitaria,
estremamente pesante,  denso di paura.
E con questo mio discorso
vorrei lanciare, appunto,
ai giovani disorientati di oggi
un messaggio universale,
perché poi di fatto questo galattico è un-
non è altro che un accenno alla
universalità del messaggio da comunicare.
Allora il nostro viaggio parte da una
piccola città della provincia di Varese
che si chiama Saronno,
dove io trovo le mie origini.
Un luogo, Saronno, privo
di una conformazione identitaria specifica
e che non mi ha trasmesso
nessun particolare senso di appartenenza.
L’aneddoto che io ricordo sempre
in relazione alla città
dove appunto trovo le mie origini
è il fatto che io l’ho sempre percepita,
fin da bambina, come un po’
un luogo borderline:
ho sempre detto che Saronno è un po’
il New Jersey di Milano.
E poi il fatto particolarmente divertente
è che il prefisso telefonico è 02,
geograficamente la città
più vicina è Como e-
la provincia di fatto è Varese.
Questo che sembra, diciamo, un’inezia,
agli occhi di una bambina
è particolarmente divertente,
proprio perché si intuisce
come questo luogo
di fatto galleggia tra diverse identità;
non è comasco, non è varesotto,
ma non è neanche milanese.
E forse la mancanza di stimoli
e l’indeterminatezza di questo luogo,
dove, ripeto, io sono nata,
mi ha in un certo senso nutrito,
regalandomi tanta curiosità,
tanta intraprendenza, tanta voglia di fare
ma soprattutto di uscire da questa
dimensione provinciale.
Ed è qui che inizia quello che definisco
il mio Reverse Gran Tour.
Se nel 1700 e nel 1800
i giovani si avventuravano in Europa
e scendevano da Inghilterra, da Germania,
per esempio, nei luoghi della classicità,
io, studentessa di Anglistica
e Germanistica,
parto dalla Facoltà di Le-
di Lingue e Letterature Straniere
dell’Università Cattolica di Milano
alla volta proprio di queste regioni,
della Germania, dell’Austria.
E grazie alla vittoria di una serie
di borse di studio - la prima a Graz -
ma già precedentemente avevo frequentato
luoghi come Rotenburg,
Monaco, Norimberga e così via.
Incomincio, diciamo, a conoscere
e a esplorare culture altre.
Il mio Grand Tour, Reverse Grand Tour,
ha avuto quindi traiettorie diverse:
non dal Nord al Sud, ma dal Sud appunto,
dai luoghi della classicità come l’Italia
verso altre regioni come appunto
l’Austria, la Germania,
prima appunto a Monaco di Baviera,
a Norimberga, a Berlino.
E poi grazie a una borsa di studio vinta
presso l’Università Cattolica di Milano,
nello specifico la facoltà di Lingue e
Letterature Straniere,
riesco a frequentare Graz
e la sua università,
specializzata proprio in Germanistica.
Questo mio peregrinare molto giovane-
questo mio peregrinare che io, diciamo,
inizio da giovanissima
perché avevo poco più di 19 anni,
poco più che ventenne,
sicuramente mi comporta uno slancio,
il fatto di voler e poter uscire
dalla mia comfort zone,
la capacità di allontanarmi
dai miei affetti più cari per molto tempo,
anni anche - di fatto sono uscita di casa
a 19 anni per poi non tornarci più -
mi ha regalato il cosiddetto proverbiale
bagaglio: cosmopolitismo,
la possibilità di conoscere una cultura
ricca come quella mitteleuropea
e di entrare in contatto
con l’utilissimo ed efficientissimo
pragmatismo anglosassone.
Torno a Milano, che è il mio baricentro
- il mio personale baricentro -
in questo viaggio che abbiamo definito
Reverse Grand Tour
per raccogliere altre informazioni;
altre, diciamo, possibilità,
altre risorse per poi tornare a viaggiare.
Vado a scrivere la mia tesi di laurea,
per esempio, a Newcastle upon Tyne,
sempre dopo aver vinto una borsa di studio
dove conduco la mia tesi di laurea
proprio sui Popular Music Studies.
Newcastle upon Tyne,
dove spicca questo dipartimento
di Popular Music Studies,
mia prima passione.
Vengo poi di nuovo richiamata
in Italia, a Milano,
quindi torna appunto
questo discorso di baricentro e,
se guardiamo questa mappa geografica
che io vi sto descrivendo,
vediamo proprio questi fili
che collegano l’Europa a Milano,
per poi ritornare, viaggiare di nuovo
alla volta di Londra
dove vinco un’altra borsa di studio
- di fatto una borsa lavoro -
e divento una social media manager
ante litteram,
stiamo parlando degli anni 2000, del 2000,
per un’azienda che si occupa-
si occupava di analisi di mercato.
Infine decido di affrontare
la grande sfida del dottorato di ricerca,
dottorato di ricerca che conduco vincendo
una borsa di studio in Gran Bretagna,
quindi volo di nuovo alla volta,
questa volta, di Londra.
Dopo l’esperienza lavorativa a Londra,
grazie alla sponsorship vinta,
torno a Milano dove di nuovo
vinco  una borsa di studio
questa volta per condurre
il mio dottorato di ricerca
in Sociologia e metodologia
della ricerca sociale
che però decido di condurre non a Milano
ma di nuovo in Gran Bretagna,
dove voglio approfondire
lo studio della sociologia,
della cultura e dei fenomeni culturali.
Grazie alle ricerche condotte proprio
a Londra e nel contesto britannico,
focalizzandomi sui paradigmi
di fruizione di musica pop,
svolgo attività di ricerca sui consumi
mediali in contesti interculturali
focalizzandomi sui paradigmi di produzione
e di fruizione di musica
in background multietnici.
E da questa mia ricerca nascono
due monografie: “Flow of Sounds”
e “Sound Matters”.
Dopo questo periodo in Gran Bretagna,
che poi si protrae a lungo nel tempo
e vivo a Londra per circa 4-5 anni,
vengo richiamata a Milano,
e quindi di nuovo torno
verso il mio baricentro
per incominciare a lavorare
presso l’Università Cattolica
e qui nel 2006 incontro Clio.
Un incontro magico
e che andrà a caratterizzare
la seconda parte della mia carriera.
Ed ecco che in questo viaggio ideale
che ha costruito la mia piccola
personale mappa, cartina geografica,
troviamo sostanzialmente un po’
il mio take away per voi,
quello che io definisco un po’
un consiglio sospeso,
come il caffè sospeso,
per tutti i giovani
che hanno vissuto un periodo
- quello dell’emergenza sanitaria e
della pandemia - sicuramente indelebile,
sicuramente indimenticabile,
ma non nel senso positivo del termine.
Oggi, per ricominciare, ritengo,
dalla mia esperienza,
che debbono essere messi in campo
tutta una serie di valori,
come il coraggio, l’intraprendenza,
che dal mio punto di vista
sono dei vaccini
contro probabilmente il problema e
l’elemento più bloccante
in questo momento che è la paura.
La paura è disabilitante,
è nemica dell’Agency,
ovvero della capacità che ognuno di noi
ha di poter realizzare e creare,
anche in maniera generativa.
E quindi il mio
consiglio sospeso è questo:
trovate il vostro baricentro,
nel mio caso è la città di Milano,
è l’Università Cattolica
che mi ha dato tante possibilità
e tante belle occasioni,
per poi lanciarvi nella vostra impresa.
La parola impresa non è un caso
che voglia dire, in lingua italiana,
abbia due accezioni:
un qualcosa che si fa con grande sforzo,
in maniera anche un po’ avventurosa,
come gli eroi dei romanzi,
ma anche l’impresa,
l’azienda è un’impresa.
E che cosa vi può aiutare?
Sicuramente la curiosità.
Abbiamo già parlato del coraggio,
dell’intraprendenza;
sono questi i vaccini alla paura.
È importante ricordare che ognuno di noi
in un cassetto, in una tasca,
ha un biglietto stropicciato
su cui ha scritto il proprio sogno.
È bello averlo, è importante
confrontarsi con esso
senza paura, con coraggio, umiltà
e tanta tanta curiosità.
Ma bisogna avere anche un po’
un business plan,
cioè bisogna avere
un piano di sostenibilità
proprio perché quello che si vuole fare
deve essere sempre sostenuto
da reali possibilità.
A mio avviso sentimenti bloccanti come
l’ansia, la paura, l’angoscia,
devono essere letteralmente oggi
da debellare con un vaccino speciale
poiché intaccano le Agency dei più giovani
e sono il peggior ostacolo
per la loro realizzazione,
per la loro crescita personale
e per la loro soddisfazione.
Bisogna, come vi dicevo, avere
un business plan oltre che un sogno
che sia sostenibile
nel medio e lungo termine.
E quindi con questo io vi lascio,
con un, diciamo, suggerimento,
un consiglio pratico,
ma anche poetico, romantico:
bisogna avere, come dicevo, sicuramente
un sogno nel cassetto ma che praticamente,
ecco questo diciamo un pragmatismo
anglosassone sempre che torna,
si possa fare.
Ringrazio i giovani studenti
di TEDx UniCatt
che mi hanno invitato
e vi saluto.
Grazie a tutti.